face à plus de 300 élus venus de toute
la france le premier ministre edouard
philippe a défendu la politique du
gouvernement rappelait l'importance de
maîtriser les dépenses et a surtout
insisté pour que les petites villes
prennent des initiatives comme par
exemple dans le plan de dynamisation des
centres villes si vous qu'il appartient
de penser et de développer les
stratégies de vos communes ce que l'état
peut faire c'est essayer de faire en
sorte de vous accompagner financièrement
et c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte de
mettre à votre disposition l'ingénierie
kim parfois manque au maire de leur côté
les maires des petites communes ont fait
entendre leurs revendications notamment
sur les questions des finances locales
et l'importance de préserver les
services publics dans la région
on s'inquiète surtout de l'accès au soin
nos petites villes doivent pouvoir
garder les moyens d'assurer l'offre de
soins à notre population que ce soit à
travers la présence des libéraux à
travers nos hôpitaux publics dans
l'yonne comme ailleurs on a des menaces
de fermeture des urgences à tonnerre
dans d'autres villes c'est un sujet
majeur qui viendra s'installer et vivre
sur un territoire où l'on ne peut plus
soignée strictement personne le premier
ministre a été bien accueilli par
l'ensemble des élus le maire d'autun
proche du gouvernement a salué son
intervention elle même je pense que le
gouvernement a une vision très juste et
très claire des choses il ne cache aucun
problème en ayant un discours de vérité
en disant on ne pourra pas tout faire on
ne prend pas tout financer
il va falloir changer il va falloir
bouger il va falloir réfléchir
différemment le diagnostic est bon la
méthode est bonne espérons ensuite que y
ait des retombées positives pour nos
petites villes après cette rencontre des
réponses devraient être apportées aux
élus lors de la conférence nationale des
territoires qui se tiendra à matignon à
la fin du mois